so you've just given us five minutes in
18 seconds of advice to someone that's
never written a screenplay if you took
that same advice let's say it's 1995
you're in your cab you're listening to
like Alanis Morissette I don't know it's
Chicago you see the woman at the gas
station the pump which has sparked this
idea you didn't even know it was gonna
be a thing yet if somebody had been sort
of this Jiminy Cricket in your ear
squeezing in as well you've got to know
this structure and you need to read this
book do you think you would have
abandoned the idea um I don't know you
know that's sort of a sad thing to think
about but I think that there's a lot of
people that get discouraged today
because they do feel like they're doing
something wrong and there is that
element out there on the message boards
on podcasts very popular podcasts that
talk about black and white define things
in black and white and it's dangerous
it's less like it's like you know people
have tried to figure out where this
industry is going and where storytelling
is going in our culture all the time
since I've been working to write
screenplays or whatever and I've seen
all the different iterations of like
well you're not able to write shouldn't
write anything period you shouldn't
write anything about the industry you
shouldn't do this you shouldn't do that
and all of its been blown up you
shouldn't write anything I mean you know
like an online bookseller an online
bookstore it wins like Oscars now you
know it's like like no don't tell me
what anything black and white is anymore
so it's dangerous and so we we can talk
about like the rules of why people care
about movies and like the the sort of
the laws of emotion and and and and I
think no one's gonna really get freaked
I think that's sort of organic stuff but
when I started off I read Michael
Hague's book and but his book and you
know I didn't even remember he I don't
think he talked a lot about formulas or
B cheats he might have talked about the
only thing I remember him talk the only
thing I remember from Michaels book was
encouragement like he just empower he
gave me hope he gave me and he
definitely encouraged me
and so that's what I always responded to
and I responded he seemed to have a
sense oh it's like that people it was
rare for something good to be written
and buddy but he did find it possible
and there were things that he he was
very much it was a hopeful book so I
think that's the only thing I got I
think that was the only screenwriting
book that I ever read a lot from I don't
know if I read the whole thing through
but I would often refer to it but then
when I started I just was like you know
I'd literally just I was like okay and I
knew something something about page 30
and page 60 or whatever and I sort of
tried to follow that but and I didn't
find it difficult to remember that
something was supposed to happen or
something like that but I was very much
on my own and I wrote whatever you know
so but I I that's why I think that we
you know it's very important for people
to remember you don't have to learn the
rules to break them you can just ignore
them if you feel like you're being
expressive and something it's cool that
you're writing something is cool and
then you start showing it to other
people and other people think it's cool
then that's the only thing we care about
because we would not have any we would
not have any Fellini we would not have
Orson Welles we probably would not have
Kurosawa
you know eventually people have to stop
listening to what people are suggesting
and nowadays you know people being told
they can't direct you know women people
of color diverse you know voices that
are like have been scourged or whatever
and all those people I just like be like
get out in my face I'm gonna I want to
say what I want to say and that's the
only way we move forward you know with
this art form is when people just say I
don't care what I'm supposed to be doing
or who's supposed to be directing or
who's supposed to be writing you know
the only time we move forward when we
when people are like well let's follow
and Bob page 23 this is supposed to
happen that's when everyone wants to
blow their brains out it's like I want
something new and that's why things like
streaming and like episodic television
did grow probably in response to
formulate a feature writing it's
probably one of the reasons because if
people were like
and I watch something else that doesn't
feel like everything else and it's
because of formula and because people
were following what they were supposed
to be doing and it's like not good but
some people have sort of a punk-rock
ethos and that's in them and they've
been that way all their lives and others
are the one in the front seat of the
class they raise their hand and be the
teacher's pet and so some people never
want to rock the boat or as others are
fine having people be totally pissed off
at them it's not about rocking the boat
it's just realizing that emotionally
that audiences don't care about when
what page number a scene is on all the
audiences are responding to is emotional
veracity if they want to be sucked in
they want to feel a part of the universe
people go into with have you ever
thought about this people walk into a
theater to watch other people on a
screen act out stuff from life and they
just watch it like why are they watching
it it's the weirdest thing when you go
into a play in a theatre people are
watching people argue on us an imaginary
stage we're gonna watch people act out
life it doesn't make any it's like
bizarre but the reason why people are
doing it is because it gets them meaning
for their struggles they go I've done
that that's me
I've fought cancer ice you know my you
know something happened to me I won the
state championship I want to be able to
win the state championship I want to be
able to come from nowhere I want to
believe I want to fall in love I want to
survive the loss of a loved one
this can happen I saw a story about
someone I mean this is why it gives us
context so that we're not walking around
going why am i doing all this you see
them moving you're like other people
have been dumped other people have been
fired other people have been
discriminated against other people
there's been injustice I suffered
injustice so are they I can live I'm
gonna fight that's why people go to
movies so that's that's the only thing
anybody cares about they don't care if
you know the point of no-return happens
on page 63 or some crap oh so if you're
writing from that place so that's that
punk rock that's just that's just
stories
that's storytelling that's conservative
storytelling liberal you know yeah it's
not gonna be political but I'm just
saying and it's anybody that's any ethos
that is the ethos so if you're going to
get in the business of the woman you
know the young lady in the front row
who's like the person who gives the
Apple to the teacher she better get it's
the it this is the this is the business
of emotion you know it's the business of
dealing of human identification with
with authentic stories and that's heavy
lifting that requires like sharing of
your life experience it is demanding
it's just this is you know a surgeon is
it's emotionally to imagine to be a
nurse it's emotionally demanding to be a
trashman because you're like looking at
people's trash you like oh my god they
threw out this photo album I mean it's
like everybody's got to deal with
something and they're like you know this
is the thing and it's like this is the
business this is that business so so you
can you know you can't get around that
and when people try and get around that
then the great actor becomes the good
actor and the great screenplay becomes
an okay movie but when you go there and
you sell the whole thing and you don't
shy away then you're Kurosawa then
you're you know then you're Eugene
O'Neill then you're writing something
you know then you're doing 12 years of
slave then you're fearless then you're
telling that you know you're doing the
thing that people go you know that's
awesome black Klansmen just like you
know amazing honest movie you know about
the truth you know it's a great movie
and it's it's about the truth and it's
like and it's emotional it's disturbing
but it's like but that's but that's
where it's Shakespeare you know that's
it it's never changed that's not new you
know that's not like avant-garde or
anything it's just that's just south and
audiences are still responding to it
because we're human beings and we still
are
spawning - a good story
you